At this point, you should have
a well-built cat clicker.
Nice work.
Now, I'm changing
the requirements one more time.
I promise this is the last time
I change requirements on you.
But I wanted to give you
an opportunity to fly on your own.
We're going to add an admin mode.
When you click the Admin button,
it makes a new area visible with the
cat's name, URL, and number of clicks.
If I go in and change the name,
say to Fluffy, and
then I hit Save, it should update
the model with the new information, and
of course, tell the views to refresh,
which also hides admin mode.
So what will you need to add?
First of all, you'll need to add
some HTML for the Admin button and
all of this stuff here.
That will probably involve a button
here, a button here, some inputs,
labels, and a form to contain these.
And come to think of it,
you can add a Cancel button too.
In terms of the model, you'll probably
want a property in your model for
whether or
not the admin view is showing.
You can set it to true or
false with your octopus function.
And then based on whether it's true or
false, the view will render this or
not render it.
In your view,
you'll have an it function.
Which I'll call, once.
That'll add the event listeners
to all of these buttons here.
Just for a review, adding event
listeners means we're telling
these elements to listen for
certain events.
In this case, click events.
So whatever the user clicks,
we run the function.
Now what about the octopus?
In your octopus you will
have a function for
opening the view when you
press the Admin button.
A function for
closing the view when you press Cancel.
And a function for
updating the current cat with
the new values when you press Save.
We'll call this version
Cat Clicker Premium Pro!
Also, remember that this exercise
here is not meant to be super easy.
Another thing to notice is that the
layout of my application keeps changing.
That's to emphasize the fact
that we're not focusing on CSS.
Your application doesn't have
to look necessarily very pretty.
Just as long as
the functionality is there.
Once you're done it won't
be a ton of code, but
if it takes you a while to do this,
that's by design.
Do remember that the more often
you work with well-organized code
the easier changes like these will be.